And her man got arrested for stalking me,
breaking the Protection order that I had.
Not only did she bail him out of jail,
she tried to keep my children away from me.
Like, she thought she was gonna uphold his parenting time
and block me from picking up my children.
Like, Nana,
like,
what the fuck are you thinking?
You are not a fucking parent!
I have found myself in life in a few positions where I.
Where literally, I was like,
oh, my god,
I thought that could never happen to me.
Like, when I was 29,
I gave birth to a daughter with down syndrome.
I was 29. I was 29.
I was in my fucking 20s.
I should not have had a child with a disability like this.
And we did genetic testing,
and it truly was luck of the draw.
Like, congratulations,
you won the genetic lottery.
Here's a kid with down syndrome.
And it's whatever.
It's not the big deal that I thought it was.
So I'm like, oh, okay.
No, I'm good.
I'm okay. And then that kid had four open heart surgeries,
and I was like, wow,
that's a lot, but okay.
We got through that.
And then, like,
do you know what I mean?
So I've just been in some situations where now I'm like,
it could happen to me,
and I wanna do everything I can to fucking prevent it.
And so I just try to, like,
learn as much As I can about anything.
Like, before I'm gonna do something,
I genuinely. I just don't like getting hurt.
I don't like being hurt physically.
I don't like being hurt emotionally.
I don't think it's necessary.
I think plenty of people have Learned all the lessons in life
to give me the guidance I need to get through
without falling into those same traps.
As I do everything I can
to protect myself from falling into those same traps,
one of the situations that I'm like,
oh, my god.
I never thought this could happen was when I separated with my ex,
and he brought a new woman into the lives of our child.
And I, to this day,
five years later,
have never fucking met this person.
She has lived with my children
and never had the fucking decency to even look me in the eyes once.
I never, never could a fucking imagine that this is the way it would be.
I don't know. I think coming from a weird family,
there has been divorce and separations and.
I mean, half my uncles and aunts are not blood related.
It's, oh,
but she married this other guy.
That's your cousin?
But that's not her dad or blah, blah, blah.
So this wasn't foreign to me.
What's foreign to me is the animosity.
Like, Nana,
I don't want him.
You can have him.
I'm not even gonna talk shit about him.
Go for it, girl.
I don't know.